welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and marvel's eternals has a new
trailer that rewrites our creation
mythology with giant armored space gods
who have had quite enough of us how long
do we have
seven days
i'm gonna break down everything you
missed in this trailer frame by frame to
explain who the eternals are their
relationship with thanos and the
celestials and how this film will crack
the mcu wide open spoiler warning in
case any of my theories are right also
we have a new latest obsession shirt
inspired by what if cosmic witness which
you can get at newrockstarsmerch.com
here we go
[Music]
five years ago thanos erased half of the
population of the universe
but the people of this planet brought
everyone back with a snap of a finger
so we open on eternals ajak and icarus
ajak is the eternal's healer and
spiritual leader who can communicate
with their creators the celestials she
lives in this remote western house and
rides up to see icarus staring her down
on top of the hill honestly a worrisome
sight to come home to like an exiled
gunslinger realizing ah damn they found
me ajak references thanos snapping away
half of all life in infinity war and
hulk snapping them back in end game
thanos is an eternal son of alars who
was an eternal brother to the eternal
zurus who is thina's father making dina
and thanos dozens now thanos was born
with a deviant gene but since he was
born to eternal parents he remains more
eternal than deviant just an outcast to
the eternal society now as an obsessive
watcher of stuff who cut my teeth on
things like lost i cannot help but see
this as the lost season 5 prologue scene
the meeting between the mystery figures
jacob and the man in black both immortal
brethren who dwell among ancient ruins
and debate over whether to intervene in
human conflicts just because similarly i
sense an antagonistic relationship
between icarus and ajax here like icarus
is someone unable to communicate with
their creators something that might have
pissed him off over the years and who
later in the trailer emotionally fires
his optic lasers at this same farmhouse
location and ajac is strangely absent
from the rest of the eternals and other
shots of this trailer just keep that in
mind meanwhile the music is a mournful
female vocal part of the score by
composer rameen jawadi who might know
from doing the amazing music of game of
thrones in westworld his music there
deeply interwoven with that show's
similar themes of immortality and flawed
creators which are at the heart of this
story moving on
the sudden return of the population
provided the necessary energy
for the emergence to begin
[Applause]
okay we see earth at the moment hulk
snapped everyone back as the sun rises
on europe population zones flood with
light to represent the sudden return of
half the world's population but before
we get there you can see faint glows in
norway and then down in central africa
representing the regions of new asgard
in turnsburg and wakanda two major
regions from which backup arrived in
that battle of earth in in-game though
some nerdy griping here this would imply
sunrise happened in moscow in this
moment which would have made it in the
middle of the night in upstate new york
also the tilt of the earth toward the
sun means that the northern hemisphere
is in the middle of summer not october
when the battle of end game was actually
set gripes said we would have really no
problem with if we were flat earthers
but last we worship at the altar of
arechem anyway imagery shows astro
bodies swirling into formation until one
star explodes in a flash of red where if
you go frame by frame through this bends
the space around it and stems outward
briefly like blood vessels in a giant
cornea similar to the way these
celestials also stem outward in these
golden lines before their form appears
we could be looking at the birth or
hatching of a celestial maybe arishim
whose color is a similar shade of red
from a cosmic body that it was using as
a gestation pod since we know ego who is
also a celestial in the mcu took the
form of a living planet his brain buried
deep in that planet's core and he
explained his origin story in tableau's
contained in shells resembling eggshells
and pilots himself around in a ship that
is modeled off of an egg now ajac
describes a coming event called the
emergence caused apparently by the
sudden return of half the population
sounds like the celestials might
consider that sudden overpopulation a
cosmic violation by the avengers that
must be fixed so the emergence could
describe the resurrection of the
deviants which might be seen by the
celestials as a population control
protocol but ajax makes it sound like
the return of life spiked energy on
earth as if the earth is feeding from
all those life forces on it the way an
egg needs to reach critical mass energy
before it hatches so this could be the
emergence of a celestial gestating
inside the earth the way ego used his
planet as a kind of shell in the comics
there is a celestial known as tiemet the
dreaming celestial who sleeps buried in
a vault underneath the mountains on
earth i'll come back to this batshit
theory but let's keep going
[Applause]
how long do we have
seven days
we see an asteroid striking the earth
creating a complete shock wave that
blasts out the clouds in the atmosphere
we could be looking at the asteroid that
formed the gulf of mexico right at the
end of the cretaceous period 66 million
years ago that killed 75 percent of life
on earth including all the non-avian
dinosaurs this could be part of the
universe creation montage that might
open the film but the editing makes it
seem like this is what causes the tidal
waves that ravage that tropical terrain
in the next shot but in that destruction
he could make out some man-built
structures that would totally not exist
during the cretaceous period so i think
this from a different scene may be
showing a more recent apocalyptic event
like the submergence of atlantis or
lemuria or the new emergence that ajax
warned about because this destruction
just seems more uncharacteristically
seismic than a tsunami or an asteroid
collision like the crust itself is
completely falling apart and opening up
from below like tsunamis are super
destructive but they don't completely
crumble land masses like that ajax tells
icarus they have seven days till this
happens obviously some biblical
allusions to the book of genesis in
which god created the earth in seven
days in marvel mythology the celestials
created the earth and apparently can
take us back out of it in the same
amount of time next clip we're eternals
[Music]
we came here seven thousand years ago
to protect humans from the deviants
[Music]
this section offers the eternal's origin
story the ten of them surrounding the
form of ereshim who drops a golden orb
into the throat of ajac awakening her
and maybe a kind of blessing that allows
ajax to be their mouthpiece kind of like
kids kids ajax getting the phone okay so
don't separate from her mommy and daddy
are going to be at the pool bar now in
the comics the eternals are one of three
races created on earth by the celestials
along with humans and deviants deviants
were beastly hostiles and eternals are
these super-powered immortals who
protect mankind from the deviants
meanwhile the celestial's origins are
explored in later comics they're said to
have been created by the aspirants in
their own image and aspirants were
created by the first firmament and all
of this hierarchy beneath a meta entity
known as the one above all considered to
be a form of comics creator jack kirby
or in the mcu stan lee or kevin feige i
don't expect the eternals film to go
that high up the ladder but the
celestials created the eternal 7 000
years ago which interestingly is when
many early human civilizations began
recording their progress with things
like trade and agriculture in our
history like there are specific regions
on earth where these civilizations began
to spring up like along the tigris and
euphrates rivers in ancient mesopotamia
the nile in egypt indus river and
pakistan and the indian subcontinent and
the yellow river in china and then over
in the western hemisphere a whole bunch
of groups along the andes mountains in
south america so these eternals with
names like fina icarus fastos gilgamesh
all correspond to figures from real
world human mythology from different
regions around the world it's because
those figures were probably based on
these eternals and then more of that
scene we saw in the teaser the seaside
tribe looking out at the ocean now
revealed to be a deviant attacking this
boy while he's fishing the deviant has
an interesting design forked tongue
nostril slits long barbells or stingers
like ones you'd see on a fish icarus
saves this kid by firing lasers from his
eyes which along with his powers of
flight bring up an interesting parallel
to a recent episode of marvel's what if
are you sure you could not fly or shoot
lasers out of your eyes or something
suggesting the collector might have had
some bass experience with another
superhero from earth icarus and as
icarus rams that deviant he flies
directly into its mouth i don't think
you can go to the collector for dental
next clip why didn't you guys help fight
thanos or any war all the other terrible
things throughout history
we were instructed not to interfere in
any human conflicts unless deviants are
involved
by who so the human character dane
whitman who will become marvel's black
knight asks the eternal cersei the
question we've all been wondering about
since the first teaser why the hell
didn't they help the avengers against
thanos well it turns out they are bound
by a kind of commandment from the
celestials to not intervene with human
conflicts unless deviants are involved
and again while thanos does possess a
deviant gene he is still mostly eternal
so perhaps the earth eternals were left
a bit unsure what to do when theena's
cousin showed up and started beating
everyone up and among these tragic human
conflicts the eternals had to just stand
aside and watch are the european
conquests of mesoamerica with drig
watching these pyramids burn and a
mushroom cloud from an atomic bomb maybe
even one of the ones from hiroshima or
nagasaki fausto's cries consoled by ajac
among some burnt ruins now fastos as the
eternals engineer might have contributed
to some human technological
breakthroughs like nuclear energy in the
early 20th century which the americans
could have taken and used for the
manhattan project against his will
leaving vastos in this profound regret
like scientists like einstein and
oppenheimer but hey imagine this
scenario you got a big date or an
important job interview or you're about
to be in front of millions of people
watching you on youtube but wait a
second what's that a huge zit who
invited that to the party well today's
sponsor frontman is here to help you
disinvite your unwelcome acne guest so
frontman fade is a skin colored cream
with proven acne fighting ingredients it
covers acne while treating it it's
dermatologists developed and made with
natural extracts
[Music]
what greasy spot look you'll be looking
better in literally 10 seconds front man
fade won't clog your pores and it's
sweat proof which is good for me because
some of my videos can get pretty intense
it's like i'm running a 10k through
these missable details and am i right so
grab yourself some frontman fade to
cover your acne while treating it head
to
befriendman.com new rockstars who use
the link in the description for 15 off
your order moving on
[Music]
okay here we see the glory shot of the
celestial eresham the judge looming over
us with amazing scale with all the space
dust swirling around him like rings
floating around saturn now there are
many celestials in the comics but from
concept art we think this movie will
feature at least erisham the judge
jimaya the analyzer nezar the calculator
and hargan the measurer who all seem to
be part of a jury panel to determine a
planet's worthiness to survive
celestials have appeared in the mcu
before like ego peter quill's dad is a
celestial in the mcu and issan the
searcher from the collector's story in
guardians of the galaxy who once wielded
the power stone also the setting of
nowhere is the severed head of a
celestial and we've seen celestial
design celebrated in the decor of the
grand masters arena on sakhar and thor
ragnarok interesting how arsham's armor
appears scarred and broken up at least
compared to the later shot of jamia
revealing arashim's glowing tissue
underneath i wonder if he could be
coming from some epic battle among
celestials perhaps what ended with
nowhere getting beheaded yes i know in
the marvel comics nowhere was beheaded
by the klintar deity null but null is a
symbiote linked with venom and carnage
might be a sony thing and marvel studios
is probably gonna retcon away from that
if they decide to ever answer that
question and the november title contains
a tiny little symbol that fades away and
then at the end of the trailer the
november 5th title card is turned
sideways in kind of a bow tie also fades
there you could see these as a symbol of
a double helix dna for ancestry and then
the other one for maybe infinity both of
them fading away like these eternals are
severing their ancestral links to the
infinite celestials onward we need to
find the others
i haven't seen some of them for
centuries
hi
hello
this is what the end of the world looks
like
at least we have front row seats okay we
embark deep into the amazon rainforest
to druid's commune now druid is known as
the moody loner of the eternals and now
he is living in present-day peru it
looks like some community isolated from
modern society perhaps using mind
control given the culti look of this
group athena and gilgamesh spar with
weapons and armor conjured from mystical
energy gilgamesh's gauntlet with a
circular pattern that actually composes
all of this mystical energy that they
use looks a bit like the infinity
gauntlet forged by itri from his model
then this volcano erupts now this is not
vesuvius from loki but i think it could
be connected to the great cataclysm from
the comics a disaster in an ancient war
that involved the atlanteans the
deviants and the celestials the ancient
kingdom of atlantis which used to be
land-based tried to repel a deviant
invasion by opening up magma pits
creating volcanic eruptions all over the
continent and the second host of the
celestials then caused a nuclear
cataclysm against the deviants that
ended up sinking the deviant-controlled
kingdom of lemuria but also atlantis
which could be the way we get neymar the
submariner in the mcu or get an answer
of what those underwater earthquakes
sequoia mentioned were all about either
way this does not seem like a natural
volcanic eruption because in that smoke
and actually later in the closer shot of
the lava you can see a bolt of golden
lightning and a violet flash and smoke
plume this just looks like the result of
some kind of interference by the
eternals and or the deviants sprite says
this is what the end of the world looks
like at least we have front row seats
which reminds me a lot of steve
buscemi's line and arm i get it look we
got front row tickets to the end of the
earth moving on you know what's never
saved the planet you're sarcasm
[Applause]
we have loved these people since the day
we arrived
so in the eternal treasure room there's
a golden statue of a cat perhaps the
egyptian goddess of bastet from whom the
wakandan panther deity bust was derived
previous teasers showed this room also
contains all kinds of historical relics
stuff from ancient rome and even the
holy grail cup from indiana jones in the
last crusade maybe makari is under house
arrest here because she intervened and
saved a human from a falling column in
one of those past disasters fastos
raises the eternal from beneath the
earth from what looks like an
archaeological dig site already underway
sprite puts on a fireworks display based
on the blue walls looks like the ancient
city of babylon that we've seen in other
footage and notice how she first shows
them the various constellations and a
viking ship rowing toward a mountainous
coastline this could be depicting the
ancient people of norway who also
benefited from divine intervention the
asgardians marvel's what if episode 1
included an italian textbook about the
tesseract with the passages describing
how the ancients followed the
constellations and from those formed
their beliefs in the gods which would
include odin of asgard but also in this
case maybe even these eternals as well
moving on when you love something
you protect it
[Applause]
icarus and cersei bond with these
ancient farmers that were shown in the
previous trailer as people they use
their powers to cultivate crops they may
have actually used parts of the embers
of genesis that we learned about in what
if which was an artifact that vastly
expands agricultural production on any
planet dane and cersei are in camden
lock in london as the double-decker bus
flips toward them but notice behind dane
there is sprite but also a duplicate
sprite to the left and then three other
duplicate cersei's calmly walking across
the street and is because one of
sprite's abilities is to cast illusions
which i assume she's using against
whatever deviants are wrecking this bus
at them but then cersei uses her power
to turn the whole bus into rose petals
hope no one was on it it's a bit similar
to when doctor strange turned an attack
into butterflies and his wizard duel
with thanos and infinity war then cersei
appears in this mysterious vast chamber
what is this place it's got triangular
panels inlaid with more of those golden
circular patterns but behind the panels
is this much bigger room with a steam
punky looking column containing a
glowing orb and this looks a lot like
the device that fastos designed on a
smaller scale in the first teaser also a
golden steampunk column with a glowing
center now using cersei's height to
scale this has got to be way too big to
fit on the eternal ship instead i'm
wondering if this could be either inside
of a celestial or inside the celestial
buried on earth because there is no
light source here other than that one
orb of the column and when cersei
touches the smaller panel of the wall it
hardens over into a wall of scales but
inside of that were some crystalline
geodes and what looks like nerve endings
maybe a kind of fusion of tissue and
minerals kind of similar to the
multi-faceted composition of the
celestials armor and tissue this could
be an extreme macro close-up of
celestial tissue moving on to the next
part
you can't protect
any of them the eternals worked together
to slay this deviant in that fishing
village and then another celestial this
is jamiah the analyzer manifests himself
out of nowhere which we also saw the
eternals doing earlier when they walked
up and this big guy beams energy from
his hands in a kind of cat's cradle that
swirls together a galaxy i assume this
is all part of some epic universal
creation montage makari leaps at
supersonic speeds and then thena is held
by this deviant but one with more
humanoid features now in the comics fina
has a forbidden romance with the deviant
leader crow who this probably is and he
has four eyes across his face maybe a
form he's shape-shifted into but as he
strokes her cheek a faint glimmer of her
golden energy glows from under her skin
next clip
[Music]
so icarus fights a flying deviant over
the amazon rainforest region of druid's
community and he lasers off its wing and
then tackles it to the ground i don't
know i just get the feeling that the
deviants might not be all that bad and
icarus is just going homelander on these
guys against the witches of the other
eternals let's move on to the last clip
i bet you've built the perfect safe
house what's this even made of vibranium
fall collection
ikea
okay so icarus and cersei are meeting
fastos in his home where he can see some
games all over the place chess connect
four coloring book game controller other
toys because fastos has a family with
kids and a husband icarus thinks the
table's made of vibranium but it's
actually the ikea fall collection
setting this movie in i'm gonna say fall
2023 maybe even the seven days after the
end game battle in october 2023 since
ajax said five years ago and originally
this movie was supposed to come out
right before one division a show that
takes place three weeks after end game
why does that matter well because the
world is still there in juan division
falcon winter soldier and spider-man
apart from home so i think we can assume
those celestials effectively effed off
we're gonna be talking a lot more about
this movie as it gets closer but you can
follow me on instagram and twitter eavos
follow and subscribe to new rockstars
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you